funcionarios iraquíes y medios estatales
culpan a ankara de realizar un ataque en
contra de civiles en la ciudad kurda de
dohuk al norte del país
ankara niega las acusaciones
el ministro de relaciones exteriores de
turquía cree que el atentado fue
realizado por el partido de los
trabajadores del kurdistán pkk y que
apenas se enteraron del ataque llamaron
al embajador de bagdad en ankara
todo el mundo sabe que turquía nunca
llevaría a cabo un ataque contra civiles
nuestra lucha contra el terrorismo
continúa en el marco de las leyes
internacionales ayer tan pronto como
estalló la noticia nos pusimos en
contacto con las instituciones
pertinentes y compartimos información
del saber
turquía realiza ataques aéreos
regularmente en el norte de irak en
contra del pkk mientras familiares de
las víctimas y el gobierno iraquí rinden
homenajes a los caídos
fuimos nos sentamos los niños estaban
jugando en el agua nuestras familias y
nuestra gente a la media hora nos
atacaron al minuto ya no sabíamos adónde
ir las mujeres se dispersaron los
hombres se dispersaron
en lo personal
con flores el ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de irak y el presidente del
gobierno regional del kurdistán
despidieron a las víctimas luego de que
fueran transportadas en un avión militar
a bagdad el pkk tomó las armas en contra
del estado turco en 1984 más de 40.000
personas han muerto en el conflicto que
busca la creación de un nuevo estado en
abril la capital de la región kurda de
irak